another one oh that's that another one
yeah I love you Tiger belly my name is
Kobe and I'm 21 years old oh here we can
I have no friends I've lived in what did
you I lived in three different states
since graduating high school and burned
every Bridge after leaving H state my
best friend lives in Australia and I
really spend most of my time alone
I find it hard because some days I can
barely leave the house because I'm not
confident in what I look like I'm super
insecure and find small talk really hard
I love to curate films but doing doing
so alone is difficult and never has fun
or fulfilling having like-minded friends
and a support system in love and care
something I'm really missing in my life
do you guys have any ideas where I can
start meeting people and become more
confident in myself love you guys Coby
the thing is is that he reminds me of
myself because I think there's something
about struggling being you know young
and trying to figure it out that there
is a thing that I miss about that of the
unknown right and when I was how old is
he 21 yeah in my early 20s I had one
friend and you know and I hardly saw him
I had people that I worked with but I
never really hung out with and another
thing before I did stand-up I couldn't
look at people in their eyes if I got
pulled over by the cops
I couldn't lock eyes with them I would
just turn away women and forget about it
I could not look at them in the eyes I
was petrified so what ended up happening
was just I would walk around Pacific
Beach in San Diego by myself back in the
90s and just like go to walk there was a
coffee shop called Zanzibar Oh mmm that
was open 24/7 and at 2:00 in the morning
I would sit there and drink espresso and
just played chess with like homeless
people mm-hmm and I would write poetry I
don't sad oh I write like little I had a
journal I would write it you know
whatever but um and I thought and I was
sober too you know it's that was the one
thing
by going to meetings I could go to meet
people you know so that's where I kind
of got you know my social you know
community say I'd recommend the opposite
this guy needs to smoke some weed chill
the [ __ ] out meet some people
you think yeah yeah yeah yeah but you're
saying that you went to meetings and you
met people was like no I didn't hang out
with them I would go to meeting and just
kind of leave but um but at that time
though it it drove me into where at
where I'm at now right like without does
that sadness without that loneliness for
me I would not if I was a good-looking
white dude in San Diego and all the
things given to me I would not be here
but because of the fact that I was
little and weird and orange hair long
right and just kind of like a lot of
zits and just meek you know those that's
what drove me to to do stand-up right so
I don't know where that's path is gonna
but a lot of times it's not a bad thing
so you're saying allow the suffering
essentially it could inspire you we
don't go shoot up a school right all
right don't do that do something
positive right but let that you know let
that be your you know motivator yeah to
come out of yourself maybe you'll create
something or do something or you'll work
hard at something and you'll overcome it
you know but a lot of times your early
20s is you know my favorite book was
Catcher in the Rye yeah just a sad you
know I used to read things like notes
from the underground oh my god that's my
favorite right I was very dark too yeah
yeah and I think that the depression
you've got to go there you got to get
weird but you've got to come out of that
like you're saying and find a way to be
constructive about your suffering
because otherwise that's a danger is
that you become a [ __ ] loser your
whole life right the sufferer yes but
make something make the diamond out of
that pressure right that nasty but he's
asking how to have friends I think is
there but you know but can I just say
something like you just said no right
notes of an undergrad was about a guy
right in a basement looking through that
little window right and just these these
thoughts Ryan it's like fear and
trembling by Kierkegaard I mean I was
into cool thing right because it fed
into my depression and my loneliness but
in many ways that inner dialogue that I
would have looking around being
antisocial you know it really helped me
drive me into where I'm at now and also
may I say that when I would anytime I
would be attracted to boys in my 20s it
was never that allowed obnoxious now he
was always the weird guy in the corner
of course emo guy that was kind of cute
but also kind of like there's something
more there yes and he was usually
depressed something wrong with those I
always reached out to those limos I was
fascinated by yeah but I would say for
this dude like what you're saying go
find something that you enjoy doing and
in the enjoying of the doing of the
thing you might find other people right
sure for instance you found your tribe
in comedy so if this guy finds it's in
surfing or whatever the [ __ ] he likes
you [ __ ] you like yeah the people that
you will party with in your 20s are not
going to be your lifelong friends anyhow
I don't like most of the people that I
party with my twenties I [ __ ] hate
today or not I hate because what I mean
like I wouldn't its I wouldn't bother
catching up with ya Sarah Lee well your
20s are a time of growth and expansion
and terrifying and they're really hyped
up to be this awesome thing and their
[ __ ] I don't think life gets good until
you're in your thirties that's where my
career started in my thirties yeah I I
got MADtv at 29 right so then in my
thirties I was on Mad and it was I was
young and excited it was exciting and
but in my 20s I just see darkness yeah
but you know what that was when I
struggled but I don't I many times I
miss it and also I'm so grateful for it
I'll even drive down like I'll go to
silver I got Drive Thompson streets and
go
I remember let that I'll pull your local
Callisto and I got a fight because the
use of these be RCS being rice and
cheese burritos they were a dollar mmm
and I remember we only had a dollar so
that we split the BRC down the middle
and we got in a fight because one was
than the other and when you have two
kids you gotta have one split set the
other one chooses the person who splits
its gonna make it as equal as possible
cause we didn't do that we gotta
fistfight different yeah the answer see
now I know why you're with this very
good answer cuz you know like real life
is open up an avocado yeah you have to
teach the comedian's out of me
yeah yeah can I see something
this podcast was really just pleasurable
to me it really it really was I know you
cancel 19 times but captain showbiz
yeah I let them cancel but my point is
is this is that huh
[Music]